cet arbre n'a pas survécu à la loire
sous ses airs de carte postale
elle est considérée comme une menace
pour bonny sur loire et où sont sur
loire depuis quelques années déjà la
loire grignote la berge et menacent
directement la station de pompage et
voici la victime le fourrage qui
alimente en eau potable environ 3000
habitants en 1986 quand on a réalisé le
forage la loire la loire du forage
aujourd'hui elle est à cinq mètres
depuis ces dernières années et mange 4 m
par an en moyenne
donc ça veut dire que dans deux ans sera
arrivé au forage elle va nous détruire
notre âge on aura plus d'eau pour éviter
le scénario catastrophe ces trois hommes
ont eu l'idée de ralentir le phénomène
avec un système qui aujourd'hui a fait
ses preuves l'installation d'un mur
étanche autour du forage il fallait
absolument que qu'on enfonce quelque
chose de profond pour empêcher l'érosion
est la seule technique c'était la seule
technique rapide c'était de la pose de
balle blanche
alors on a posé des palplanches jusqu'à
sept mètres de profond et donc on a posé
sa sur 40 mètres de long une opération
provisoire avec une enveloppe de 50000
euros pour protéger la station de
pompage financé à 50% par l'état
la municipalité de bonny sur loire
cherche un nouveau point de forage mais
pour l'instant pas de panique
nos continuera de couler